hey what's up guys my name is first of
all i want to thank all of you for
watching my videos because i have just
hit
300 000 subscribers on this channel
which
is absolutely insane it blows my mind i
honestly i never really had a goal above
a hundred thousand
that to me in itself was amazing so
thank you
to all of you who think my videos are
worth watching because
i love you all now that we've hit 300
000 subscribers i have been thinking
in my mind where this channel is going
what i want to do with this
if i'm happy with how things are going
and if there are changes
that need to be made and as you can
probably tell by the title of this video
i think there are changes that have to
be made now the first thing i want to
say
is that nothing bad is happening so
don't be afraid that your content that
you want to watch is going away
things are going to change but whatever
content of mine you like
there's going to be more of it in some
form or another as you have probably
noticed
i've started diversifying the kind of
videos that i make i used to pretty much
only make tutorials on c
plus and then game engine like design
and architecture and development
and other things i mean in the way in
the past i used to make like java videos
and all that this channel has always
really been focused
on education and specifically teaching
people how to either write code or make
game engines or games that at its core
is why i made this channel and to be
honest
i actually had a channel before this one
and it's a long story which i'm
not going to get into now but the point
is i made this channel to teach people
how to make games and how to make game
engines as well as programming in
general lately though now that making
youtube videos is part of my job
i've wanted to make more than just
programming in game engine related
videos
understandably i think and this is
probably best reflected by
all of the reaction videos that i have
made even though they
are technical and i try to help my
audience
understand a little bit more about
what's going on in terms of all the
technical details based on my knowledge
they're still not exactly aligned with
the rest of the content on this channel
now i really like making those videos
they're fun for me to make i don't make
them because they get popular
although i mean it's great that they do
obviously i make them because i enjoy
making them and
obviously people enjoy watching them but
i don't think that this channel
is the place for those kinds of videos
so by now you can probably tell where
this is going
i'm going to be making another channel
for those kinds of
videos now for those of you paying
attention you may have noticed that a
few months ago i actually did make a new
channel my
personal channel my yanchanikov channel
the thing is though
i don't want to upload game related like
reaction videos or technical breakdowns
onto that channel either because to me
that's more of a personal channel it has
or should have nothing to do with
programming or games or anything like
that
it's more about my other interests
whether that be music
or cooking or like lifestyle vlog
related content
that's what the personal channel is for
it's more about my life not specifically
the whole programming like game engine
development side of that so what i'm
going to be doing is making a new kind
of churno channel
a channel that's going to be called
morturno and as a title may suggest
that channel is going to be an extension
of this channel
but for more or less like chill
commentary related style videos
like reaction videos it'll generally be
a lot more game
focused so for example microsoft flight
simulator is coming out i think today
i'm going to be uploading content on
that to that channel because it doesn't
really fit onto this channel and i'm
really excited to just
have that channel as more of a chill
space where i can just talk about
whatever it is i want to talk about
but also not feel like i'm providing you
guys who are subscribed to this channel
with content that you don't necessarily
want to see
so in summary there are three channels
that i have
and plan on using this channel the
churno which is the primary channel this
is the
this is my main channel this is the
channel that i'm going to be spending
the most
time on it's going to be the channel
that i upload the highest quality videos
to
this channel is all about programming
game development game engine development
and specifically
educational content around those topics
of as high quality as i can possibly
make it the second channel is
more cherno that channel is a lot more
chill and it's more kind of commentary
style
it's more about me watching perhaps
videos that people want me to watch and
commenting on the technical aspects of
them maybe playing some games and
commenting on the technical aspects of
that as well and just really like
game related stuff that doesn't
particularly fit onto like this
this cherno channel this style is also
going to be a lot more relaxed and
probably not as high quality as this
channel and then finally there's the
yarn channel
channel the personal channel which is
probably the one that's going to see the
least amount of videos uploaded to just
because
i'm quite busy these days but that
channel is more about
having fun and uploading uploading
videos that have nothing to do with
game engines or programming or anything
like that so
mostly i would expect music cooking just
random live streams maybe
stuff like that so now that you know all
of these three different channels
it's time to pick a side if you are only
interested in my reaction videos or my
commentary videos you don't want to see
these videos about
game engines or c-plus plus or hazel or
anything like that
then unsubscribe from this channel and
subscribe to the morecherno channel
because that channel which of course i
will have links i'll have all three
channels linked in the description below
just so that no one's confused
that channel is going to be all about
reactions commentary all of that stuff
so please just unsubscribe from this
channel and subscribe to that channel so
that you get the content
that you want also if you're interested
in the personal channel and the stuff
that i'm going to be uploading there
then check that channel out as well i
obviously don't want to be shoving
content down your throat that you did
not subscribe to or that you don't want
to see so hopefully these three channels
and being able to subscribe to the ones
that you care about
is just going to make life easier for
you which is what i'm all about
i'm glad that's out of the way in other
news i will of course be continuing to
stream on twitch i'm really excited to
be doing that at least twice a week
we'll both be developing the game engine
series live there on twitch as well as
working on hazel dev and maybe art
related stuff
and other game engine related stuff
there's so much stuff that i want to do
and live streaming it is obviously a
huge motivator as well as a really good
time for me and for others
so i will be using that platform a lot
more in the future as well
and as mentioned previously all of those
live streams will be archived to a
youtube channel for all eternity that
patrons will have access to
now about the merch a lot of people have
been asking me to put up
things other than clothing and things
other than this turkey including the
cheona logo and the hazel logo i have
done that so if you go to
chernothreds.com there'll be a link in
description you'll see a lot more
merch that you can buy including like
notebooks and i mean there's a lot of
stuff there's even socks
so definitely check that out if you are
interested and of course it really does
help support the channel so huge thank
you
to those people who want some of that
awesome
merch that's right you can finally buy
this channel pillow that has been in the
background
of a lot of my videos for like the last
three years
and in fact to be honest i'm really keen
to get some hazel match
as well because i don't actually have
any at the moment that'll be cool
all right i think that's about it i hope
you guys enjoy this little
update hopefully organizing my content
into these three channels is going to
make
your lives a little bit easier i think
it's going to make my life a bit easier
as well because i can just
relax on my other channels and not have
to provide content necessarily for
people who subscribe to this channel to
be honest i'm really looking forward to
just diversifying the content in general
and i hope that you will also enjoy all
of my new content now in terms of 300
000 subscriber specials
i mean i remember a few months ago i
think i mentioned that my 200 000
subscriber special would be like a q a
video
and a lot of you left comments and
instagram messages and stuff like that
and to be honest like
just completely just i don't know what
happened to that just didn't have time
to make that and it's already 300 000
subscribers so i think if there's a
special video you want me to upload to
actually celebrate 300 000 subscribers
other than a q a
let me know in the comments below
obviously celebrating such a milestone
is
thanks to you it's more about you guys
so if there's something you want me to
do
let me know but other than that thank
you all for watching my videos thank you
all for subscribing thank you all for
being here
i think we've built an amazing community
here over the last
like eight years or so and honestly
there's so much exciting content coming
in the future that i just can't wait to
make thank you all i will see you next
time
[Applause]
[Music]
goodbye
[Music]
you